[Music]
wait let them think they have the higher
ground
fire send in Infantry take their
position on the higher
ground
[Applause]
covery from the West Pi's their
flakes ni
uncover the
[Music]
cannon what now sir we
Pon off the ice
withdraw cut off their
[Music]
retreat
I found the crown of France in the
gutter I picked it up with the tip of my
sword and placed it to top my own
head
do I need to warn you of my
[Music]
indiscretions no
madame is where I have been concern
you no
[Music]
down
if you look down you'll see a
surprise and once you see it you'll
always want
[Music]
it who did
this they
did no they did not
be
sensible who set these
fires the
Majesty they
did he'd rather burn his own city than
negotiate with me I didn't think he had
the
[Music]
courage
oh look at to St Petersburg
and I haven't burned that
too General we are
discovered
good
wait nice it's a CL
Dr I'm not built like other
men generals got GED in their
masses move along now those in power
only see me as a Gro unfit for higher
office just like witches at black m but
I follow in the footsteps of Alexander
the Great and
Caesar evil minds plot destruction if
you look down you'll see a
surprise once you see it you will always
want it Sorcerer of death Construction
I must warn you I will not leave a
second of
command I will win by fire I am destined
for
greatness I found the crown of France in
the
gutter and place it the top my own
head
is where the
burning you want to be great but you
want nothing without me say
it I believe I speak for all of us we
will all sleep again without This
Vermin whose country are we
in
[Music]
mine